Hey Torontonians, recycling is more than a routine. It's a vital responsibility. By recycling properly, you help conserve resources, reduce energy use in greenhouse gas emissions, and protect the environment. Toronto's Blue Bin Recycling Program ensures the majority of the right items are recovered and transformed into new products. Recycling right is important and impactful. Let's work together and make a difference, because small actions lead to big change. For more tips on recycling, visit toronto.ca slash recycle right.
嘿，多伦多人，回收不仅仅是一种日常习惯，更是一项至关重要的责任。通过正确回收，您可以帮助节约资源，减少能源消耗和温室气体排放，并保护环境。多伦多的蓝色回收箱计划确保了大部分可回收物品能够被回收并转化为新产品。正确回收既重要又具有影响力。让我们携手合作，做出改变，因为小小的行动也能带来巨大的变化。欲了解更多回收建议，请访问 toronto.ca/recycle-right。
Some stories are so profound, so unimaginable, that they stay with us forever. The Unthinkable is the latest podcast from Casefile Presents, hosted by two of Australia's leading voices in true crime, Vicky Petratus and Emily Webb. The series delves into tales of ordinary people who have faced extraordinary, often devastating events and emerged forever changed. From survivors of traumatic events, to victims of relentless stalking, and even those who've confronted some of Australia's most notorious criminals, The Unthinkable explores the depths of human resilience. The first two episodes feature the incredible story of Louisa Hope, a woman who survived Sydney's Lindt Cafe siege in 2014. Both episodes will be available for free on Sunday November 10 wherever you get your podcasts,
有些故事深刻到令人难以想象，以至于它们永远留在我们心中。《不可思议》（The Unthinkable）是 Casefile Presents 推出的最新播客，由澳大利亚两位顶尖的真实犯罪节目主持人维基·佩特拉图斯（Vicky Petratus）和艾米丽·韦伯（Emily Webb）主持。该系列深入探讨了普通人面对非凡且往往是毁灭性事件，并从此彻底改变的故事。从创伤事件的幸存者，到遭受持续跟踪的受害者，甚至那些面对过澳大利亚最臭名昭著罪犯的人，《不可思议》探索了人类韧性的深度。前两集讲述了路易莎·霍普（Louisa Hope）的不可思议的故事，她是在 2014 年悉尼林特咖啡馆人质劫持事件中幸存下来的女性。这两集将于 11 月 10 日星期日免费上线，您可以在任何收听播客的平台上找到。
with episodes dropping weekly after that. Be sure to follow The Unthinkable so you don't miss an episode. Stay tuned until the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. 26-year-old Sean Stouty's Facebook page was an extension of himself. He once shared a post on the social media website that read,
此后每周更新一集。请务必关注《不可思议》，以免错过任何一集。请收听今天节目的结尾，届时将播放预告片。我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。26 岁的肖恩·斯托蒂（Sean Stouty）的 Facebook 页面是他自我的延伸。他曾在该社交媒体网站上分享过一条帖子，写道：
I don't know how I would live if I was not on Facebook. Multiple times a day, Sean would post whatever random thoughts popped into his head, from asking if platypuses could be kept as pets to musing about celebrities. He quoted his favourite television shows and summarised recently viewed episodes of Malcolm in the Middle. He was also notably introspective, writing, "...starting next week, I'm going to act totally normal. Shaun had been diagnosed with autism, a developmental disorder that impaired his ability to communicate
“如果我不用 Facebook，我不知道该怎么活。”肖恩每天多次发布脑海中闪过的任何随机想法，从询问鸭嘴兽是否可以作为宠物饲养，到对名人的沉思。他引用自己最喜欢的电视节目，并总结最近观看的《马尔科姆的一家》（Malcolm in the Middle）剧集。他还特别善于内省，写道：“……从下周开始，我要表现得完全正常。”肖恩被诊断出患有自闭症，这是一种损害他沟通能力的各种发育障碍。
and interact. He'd also suffered from seizures since birth, which prevented him from living independently. Attempts to house Shaun in an assisted living facility hadn't panned out, and he was unable to work due to being easily overwhelmed. As a young adult, Sean still lived at home with his parents and three younger sisters in the city of Springfield, Missouri. Sean's autism made it difficult for him to understand social cues and other people's behaviour. Although those who knew Sean thought he was nice and friendly, he could come across as impolite or insensitive to neurotypical strangers. He was aware of how his condition impacted others,
以及互动能力。他从出生起就患有癫痫，这使他无法独立生活。将肖恩安置在辅助生活设施的尝试并未成功，而且由于容易感到不知所措，他无法工作。作为一名年轻人，肖恩仍然与父母和三个妹妹住在密苏里州的斯普林菲尔德市。肖恩的自闭症使他难以理解社交暗示和其他人的行为。尽管认识肖恩的人认为他既友善又和蔼，但在神经正常的陌生人看来，他可能会显得不礼貌或迟钝。他意识到自己的病情对他人造成了影响，
lamenting on his Facebook page, lamenting on his Facebook page, I'm not a bad person. I have social problems. All I want is to live a normal life. Every so often, Sean posted about his home life, anything from how his family's cars were getting their tyres pressure checked to venting about his dirty bedroom carpet. Then, in early April 2012, Sean's Facebook posts took on a new focus. He began sharing how his father, Mark Stouty, had started acting strangely. As Sean only had several online followers and they rarely engaged with his content, these posts drew little attention. Despite this, Sean continued to provide daily reports about his father's increasingly odd behaviour.
并在他的 Facebook 页面上感叹道：“我不是一个坏人。我有社交问题。我只想过正常的生活。”肖恩偶尔会发布关于他家庭生活的内容，从他家人的汽车轮胎气压检查情况，到抱怨他脏兮兮的卧室地毯。然后，在 2012 年 4 月初，肖恩的 Facebook 帖子有了新的重点。他开始分享他的父亲马克·斯托蒂（Mark Stouty）是如何开始表现得有些奇怪的。由于肖恩只有几个在线关注者，而且他们很少与他的内容互动，这些帖子几乎没有引起注意。尽管如此，肖恩还是继续提供关于他父亲日益古怪行为的每日报告。
According to Sean, Mark Stouty was suffering mental problems that were also weakening his body. Quote, My father is slowly starting to have problems with the driving and accomplishing anything. When he drove a car, the car swerved a little bit. I had to help him keep the car direction straight and properly turning." In another post, he claimed his father was so insane that Sean didn't want to be friends with him anymore. On Saturday, April 7, Sean posted, My father is slowly getting sicker. His voice is slurred. His walking is wobbly. His body is more
据肖恩说，马克·斯托蒂患有精神问题，这些问题也削弱了他的身体。引用：“我父亲开始在驾驶和完成任何事情方面出现问题。当他开车时，车子会稍微偏离方向。我不得不帮他保持车子直线行驶并正确转弯。”在另一篇帖子中，他声称他父亲疯得厉害，肖恩不想再和他做朋友了。4 月 7 日星期六，肖恩发帖说：“我父亲病得越来越重了。他的声音含糊不清。他走路摇摇晃晃。他的身体比平时更
tired than normal. He is sleeping in bed longer than us. He may collapse under his weight at any time." The next day, Sean wrote that his father had spent half the day in bed and was struggling with basic physical tasks. Then on Monday, April 9, Sean announced, My father died. He lived a full life. The cause of death is a stroke. His funeral is this week. His belongings now belong to my sisters. Sean Stouty wasn't the only one who had noticed Mark's declining health. Two days before Mark's death, he'd attended a recording session with his band, a blues outfit called Messing With Destiny. As the band's lead singer and guitarist, Mark had to project excitement and enthusiasm in order to put on a great show. This came naturally to Mark because music was his life's passion. It had even drawn him to his wife,
累。他睡在床上的时间比我们长。他随时可能因体重而倒下。”第二天，肖恩写道，他父亲在床上躺了大半天，在进行基本的身体活动时感到吃力。然后在 4 月 9 日星期一，肖恩宣布：“我父亲去世了。他度过了充实的一生。死因是中风。他的葬礼在本周举行。他的财物现在归我的姐妹们所有。”肖恩·斯托蒂并不是唯一注意到马克健康状况恶化的人。在马克去世前两天，他参加了与他的乐队的录音会议，这是一个名为“Messing With Destiny”的蓝调乐队。作为乐队的主唱和吉他手，马克必须表现出兴奋和热情，才能呈现一场精彩的演出。这对马克来说很自然，因为音乐是他一生的热情所在。它甚至让他结识了他的妻子，
Diane, who was a church organist, and the couple endeavoured to pass their love of music down to their children. Messing with the Destiny was gradually gaining success, booking semi-regular gigs in neighbouring cities and making a small amount of money. So during their evening recording session on Friday April 6, Mark's bandmates were dismayed to see him uncharacteristically distracted, confused and slurring his words. They didn't think Mark was drunk, but wondered if his poor diet, lack of exercise or other unhealthy vices might have caught up with him. Mark also had bipolar disorder, a mental condition hallmarked by drastic mood swings
黛安（Diane），她是一位教堂管风琴师，这对夫妇努力将他们对音乐的热爱传给孩子们。Messing With Destiny 逐渐获得成功，在邻近城市预订了半定期的演出，并赚取了少量收入。因此，在 4 月 6 日星期五晚上的录音会议期间，马克的乐队成员惊讶地发现他一反常态地心不在焉、困惑且说话含糊不清。他们不认为马克喝醉了，但怀疑他糟糕的饮食、缺乏锻炼或其他不健康的恶习是否已经对他造成了影响。马克还患有双相情感障碍，这是一种以剧烈情绪波动为特征的精神疾病，
and manic episodes. Perhaps he was just going through a rough period. Mark stayed hydrated and went on several walks outside hoping to shake whatever ailed him. Despite losing his appetite, becoming increasingly lethargic and even vomiting, Mark didn't go to the doctor, nor did his family push him to seek medical treatment. It seemed like he just had a bad case of the flu, nothing that he wouldn't overcome in time. Saturday April 7 was Mark's 61st birthday and he went to a friend's house to celebrate. His friend was troubled by Mark's yellow complexion. Diane Stouty checked on her husband throughout the night but he was too fatigued to say much at all. By Sunday April 8, Mark was so sick that he couldn't go to church. His absence was surprising,
以及躁狂发作。也许他只是经历了一段艰难时期。马克保持水分，并在外面散了几次步，希望能摆脱困扰他的任何疾病。尽管失去了食欲，变得越来越嗜睡，甚至呕吐，但马克并没有去看医生，他的家人也没有催促他寻求医疗救治。这看起来就像他只是得了严重的流感，没什么他不能及时克服的。4 月 7 日星期六是马克 61 岁的生日，他去了一个朋友家庆祝。他的朋友对马克蜡黄的肤色感到不安。黛安·斯托蒂整晚都在查看她丈夫的情况，但他太疲惫了，几乎说不出话来。到了 4 月 8 日星期日，马克病得太重，无法去教堂。他的缺席令人惊讶，
as the Stoutys were devout Christians and prominent members of their church community. The rest of the family went without Mark, who stayed behind to rest. Some time after they returned home, they found Mark in bed, unconscious and unresponsive. Diane called emergency services, but there was nothing they could do. Mark was dead. A ring of blood had dried around Mark's mouth. Other than that, he looked normal and had no signs of injury. Diane Stouty was able to detail her husband's final hours which culminated in him suffering three seizures on Sunday. He had never had a seizure before. The last one occurred 45 minutes before Diane found Mark not breathing. She said
因为斯托蒂一家是虔诚的基督徒，也是他们教会社区的杰出成员。其余家人在没有马克的情况下去了教堂，马克留下来休息。他们回家后不久，发现马克躺在床上，失去知觉且没有反应。黛安拨打了紧急服务电话，但他们无能为力。马克去世了。一圈血迹在马克的嘴边干涸。除此之外，他看起来很正常，没有任何受伤的迹象。黛安·斯托蒂能够详细描述她丈夫最后的时光，这些时光最终导致他在周日遭受了三次癫痫发作。他以前从未有过癫痫发作。最后一次发生在黛安发现马克停止呼吸前 45 分钟。她说
she'd wanted to call 911 sooner but Mark had insisted that he didn't want to go to hospital. insisted that he didn't want to go to hospital. Diane explained that Mark had diabetes and was developing Alzheimer's which was gradually destroying his mental functions. This was in addition to liver problems he'd acquired from drinking alcohol in excess. Mark was also a long time cigarette smoker and would sometimes smoke cannabis. Upon observing Mark's body and taking his lifestyle and health into account, the county medical examiner concluded that the 61-year-old must have died of natural causes. They didn't think it was necessary to perform any tests or an autopsy. Diane Stouty announced Mark's untimely passing on her Facebook
她本想早点拨打 911，但马克坚持说他不想去医院。黛安解释说，马克患有糖尿病，并且正在发展成阿尔茨海默病，这正在逐渐破坏他的精神功能。此外，他还因酗酒而患有肝脏问题。马克也是一名长期吸烟者，有时会吸食大麻。在观察了马克的尸体并考虑到他的生活方式和健康状况后，县法医得出结论，这位 61 岁的老人一定是死于自然原因。他们认为没有必要进行任何检查或尸检。黛安·斯托蒂在她的 Facebook 上宣布了马克不幸去世的消息，
page, telling the couple's devastated friends that her husband of 27 years had reached his eternal home. She quoted from the Gospel of John, "...let not your hearts be troubled. Believe in God. Believe also in me." Mark was cremated and his ashes scattered at a lake. The remaining members of Messing With Destiny performed a musical tribute for Mark at his memorial service and played his favourite song of theirs, titled Darkest Hour. Mark's daughter Rachel paid tribute to her father with a poem by influential German writer Johann Wolfgang von Goethe. Over the hilltops is calm. In all the treetops you feel hardly a breath of air.
告诉这对夫妇悲痛欲绝的朋友，她结婚 27 年的丈夫已经回到了永恒的家。她引用了《约翰福音》中的话：“……你们心里不要忧愁。信神，也当信我。”马克被火化，骨灰撒在湖里。Messing With Destiny 的其余成员在马克的追悼会上为他进行了音乐致敬，并演奏了他最喜欢的他们的歌曲，名为《最黑暗的时刻》（Darkest Hour）。马克的女儿瑞秋（Rachel）用有影响力的德国作家约翰·沃尔夫冈·冯·歌德（Johann Wolfgang von Goethe）的一首诗向她的父亲致敬。“山顶上是一片宁静。在所有的树梢上，你几乎感觉不到一丝微风。
The little birds fall silent in the woods. Just wait. Soon, you'll also be at rest." Mark's death was a huge blow to his family's dynamic. By all accounts, the Stouties were happy and full of love, support, and understanding. Mark was a devoted stay-at-home dad, as all of the Stoutie children were reliant on their parents in their own way. Eldest child and only son, Sean, lived with them on account of his health. 24-year-old Sarah, a university graduate who had accrued a large student loan debt, was struggling to find a job. 22-year-old Rachel was studying art history at college while pursuing her love of painting
林中的小鸟不再鸣叫。等着吧。很快，你也会安息。”马克的去世对他的家庭动态是一个巨大的打击。据各方描述，斯托蒂一家幸福美满，充满了爱、支持和理解。马克是一位全职的居家父亲，因为所有的斯托蒂孩子都以各自的方式依赖他们的父母。长子也是唯一的儿子肖恩，因健康原因与他们住在一起。24 岁的莎拉（Sarah）是一名大学毕业生，背负着巨额学生贷款债务，一直在努力找工作。22 岁的瑞秋（Rachel）在大学学习艺术史，同时追求她对绘画的热爱
and music. The Stouties' youngest child, an 11-year-old girl, Casevile, we'll refer to as Tia, had learning difficulties. Mark and Diane were very proud of their children. Diane referred to them as little professors, as each was an expert in their own special interests. 51-year-old Diane was the family breadwinner. She was a cardiology nurse who primarily worked from home assessing insurance company claims. At times, her income was not enough to support the family of six, so Mark took on odd jobs for extra cash.
和音乐。斯托蒂家最小的孩子，一个 11 岁的女孩，我们称之为蒂亚（Tia），有学习障碍。马克和黛安为他们的孩子感到非常自豪。黛安称他们为“小教授”，因为每个人都是各自特殊兴趣领域的专家。51 岁的黛安是家庭的经济支柱。她是一名心脏科护士，主要在家工作，评估保险公司的索赔。有时，她的收入不足以养活六口之家，所以马克会做些零工来赚取额外收入。
Prior to Mark's passing, the Stouties lived in a small home in Springfield's suburban West. Their house needed a lot of work and the neighbourhood had some problems. Sean Stouty often vented about this on his Facebook page, going so far as to write, I need a better house to live in. His father's modest life insurance payout of $20,000 helped the family relocate to a larger house in a nicer area. Sean was delighted by the move. He posted about it online, writing, I am going to move out of a neighborhood of hell to a neighbourhood that has a low crime rate, has good people, has good schools, and has properly built houses."
在马克去世之前，斯托蒂一家住在斯普林菲尔德郊区西部的一所小房子里。他们的房子需要大量的修缮，而且社区也存在一些问题。肖恩·斯托蒂经常在 Facebook 页面上发泄对此的不满，甚至写道：“我需要一个更好的房子住。”他父亲 2 万美元的适度人寿保险赔付帮助全家搬到了一个更好地区的一所更大的房子里。肖恩对这次搬家感到非常高兴。他在网上发帖写道：“我要搬离一个地狱般的社区，搬到一个犯罪率低、有好人、有好学校、房子建造得当的社区。”
In late April, Sean opened a new Facebook account in preparation for his fresh start. He continued posting near-daily whatever piqued his interest, but over the following months his online activity lessened. Sean acknowledged this on Saturday August 4, 2012, writing that he was sharing fewer posts than he had previously. Then he stopped posting altogether. Then he stopped posting altogether. By September 2012, five months after the unexpected death of Mark Stouty, his family had settled in to their new home. Then, on Sunday September 2, the Stouties arrived at their weekly church service with another notable absence. 26-year-old Sean was unable to attend as he was bedridden after suffering flu-like symptoms for
4 月下旬，肖恩开设了一个新的 Facebook 账户，为他的新生活做准备。他继续几乎每天发布任何引起他兴趣的内容，但在接下来的几个月里，他的在线活动减少了。肖恩在 2012 年 8 月 4 日星期六承认了这一点，写道他分享的帖子比以前少了。然后他完全停止了发帖。到 2012 年 9 月，在马克·斯托蒂意外去世五个月后，他的家人已经在新家安顿下来。然后，在 9 月 2 日星期日，斯托蒂一家参加了每周的礼拜仪式，但又有一个明显的缺席。26 岁的肖恩无法参加，因为他在遭受了流感样症状后卧床不起
weeks. He could do little else but rest and stay hydrated in between long painful bouts of vomiting, head and muscle aches and appetite loss. When the Stouties returned home from church, they found Shaun unconscious on his bedroom floor. A ring of dried blood had formed around his mouth. Just like his father months earlier, Shaun had died unexpectedly after enduring a mysterious illness. On this occasion, the county medical examiner performed an autopsy. It revealed that Sean had a congenital kidney defect, signs of brain damage and a stroke, as well as damage to his central nervous system. Given Sean's history of seizures and other health issues, the medical examiner assumed that the young man had been struck down by a pre-existing condition.
数周。在长时间痛苦的呕吐、头痛、肌肉酸痛和食欲不振之间，他几乎什么也做不了，只能休息和补充水分。当斯托蒂一家从教堂回家时，他们发现肖恩昏倒在卧室地板上。他嘴边形成了一圈干涸的血迹。就像几个月前的他父亲一样，肖恩在经历了一场神秘的疾病后意外去世了。这一次，县法医进行了尸检。结果显示，肖恩患有先天性肾脏缺陷、脑损伤和中风的迹象，以及中枢神经系统受损。考虑到肖恩有癫痫发作和其他健康问题的病史，法医推测这名年轻人是被一种既有的疾病击倒的。
Sean's death was officially ruled as being due to prior medical issues. The sudden deaths of Mark and Sean so close together left the local community reeling. Friends of the Stouties were shocked that a loving, pious family could have such awful luck. Two days after Sean's death, Diane Stouty posted a short tribute to her son on her Facebook page. It's been hard for me to come up with the right words, Diane wrote, but here goes. On Sunday, my oldest child, Sean, died. Although he had been sick lately, we thought he was getting better. Diane went on to thank those who had been keeping her family in their prayers, quote,
肖恩的死被正式裁定为由既往医疗问题引起。马克和肖恩如此接近的突然死亡让当地社区感到震惊。斯托蒂家的朋友们感到震惊，一个充满爱心、虔诚的家庭怎么会有如此糟糕的运气。在肖恩去世两天后，黛安·斯托蒂在她的 Facebook 页面上发布了一段对她儿子的简短致敬。“对我来说，想出合适的词语很难，”黛安写道，“但还是写吧。周日，我的长子肖恩去世了。虽然他最近一直生病，但我们以为他正在好转。”黛安接着感谢那些一直为她的家人祈祷的人，引用：
May we have a portion of the peace Sean now enjoys. Everyone was devastated for the now family of four who grew noticeably reclusive after Sean's death. His remains were cremated, but unlike his father, there was no funeral or memorial to honour his life. Diane Stouty seemed to be taking the loss of her husband and son in her stride. She focused on taking care of her three daughters, Sarah, Rachel and Tia, and threw herself into her music and church commitments. The local community rallied around Diane, who responded well to the guidance and support provided by her pastors. Even Diane's daughter, Rachel, was struck by how well her
“愿我们能分享肖恩现在享受的那份平静。”每个人都为这个现在只剩下四口之家的家庭感到悲痛，他们在肖恩去世后变得明显孤僻。他的遗体被火化了，但与他的父亲不同，没有举行葬礼或追悼会来纪念他的一生。黛安·斯托蒂似乎从容地应对了丈夫和儿子的离世。她专注于照顾她的三个女儿——莎拉、瑞秋和蒂亚，并全身心投入到她的音乐和教会事务中。当地社区团结在黛安周围，她对牧师提供的指导和支持反应良好。甚至黛安的女儿瑞秋也对她的
mother coped in the aftermath of Sean's inexplicable death. Rachel posted on her Facebook page, don't think I've seen mum so chilled out like this in a long time. But this moment of calm was short lived. Nine months after the death of Shaun, the Stouty family was hit with more misfortune. 24-year-old Sarah Stouty had been found unconscious in bed after suffering severe flu-like symptoms. Diane bundled her eldest daughter into her car and rushed her to the hospital. her eldest daughter into her car and rushed her to the hospital. By the time Sarah arrived at the emergency department, her condition was so dire that she was swiftly admitted to the intensive care unit. Doctors soon discovered that Sarah wasn't just dealing with a nasty strain of the flu. Her kidneys had shut down, her pancreas was failing, and her brain was
母亲在肖恩莫名其妙死亡后的应对方式感到震惊。瑞秋在她的 Facebook 页面上写道：“不记得我有多久没见过妈妈这么冷静了。”但这种平静的时刻是短暂的。在肖恩去世九个月后，斯托蒂一家又遭遇了更多不幸。24 岁的莎拉·斯托蒂在遭受严重的流感样症状后被发现昏倒在床上。黛安把她的大女儿抱进车里，冲向医院。当莎拉到达急诊科时，她的情况非常危急，被迅速送进了重症监护室。医生很快发现莎拉不仅仅是患上了严重的流感。她的肾脏已经衰竭，胰腺功能丧失，大脑正在
hemorrhaging blood. Sarah had suffered a total body collapse. She'd had numerous strokes and seizures and most likely wouldn't survive. Multiple tests were performed but the cause of Sarah's illness remained a mystery. Diane Stouty took to Facebook to inform her friends of her family's latest tragedy. She wrote, asking for prayers as my daughter Sarah is in critical condition in the ICU tonight. She followed this up with an image that featured the biblical verse, "'Rejoice in our confident hope, be patient in trouble, and keep on praying.'" As news of Sarah Stouty's ordeal spread, Springfield police received a troubling phone call. The man on the other line said he wished to remain anonymous
出血。莎拉经历了全身崩溃。她经历了多次中风和癫痫发作，很可能无法存活。进行了多次检查，但莎拉的病因仍然是个谜。黛安·斯托蒂在 Facebook 上向她的朋友们通报了她家人的最新悲剧。她写道，请求祈祷，因为我的女儿莎拉今晚在重症监护室情况危急。她随后附上了一张图片，上面有圣经经文：“‘在指望中要喜乐，在患难中要忍耐，祷告要恒切。’”随着莎拉·斯托蒂遭遇的消息传开，斯普林菲尔德警方接到了一个令人不安的电话。电话那头的男人说他希望保持匿名，
but claimed to be a pastor at the Stouties' church. Upon hearing about Sarah's illness, he'd become overwhelmed with concern. Through his work, he had encountered many people who'd experienced considerable hardship and loss. However, he had never come across a family who had endured so much indiscriminate death in such a short time span as the Stouties. He brought up the close timing of Mark and Sean's deaths, which had been excused on account of their respective histories of poor health. But now the otherwise healthy Sarah was fighting for her life in a similar scenario.
但声称是斯托蒂家教会的一名牧师。在听到莎拉的病情后，他感到非常担忧。通过他的工作，他遇到过许多经历过相当大困难和损失的人。然而，他从未见过像斯托蒂一家这样在如此短的时间内遭受如此多无差别死亡的家庭。他提到了马克和肖恩死亡时间相近的问题，这些死亡曾因他们各自的健康状况不佳而被解释。但现在，原本健康的莎拉也在类似的情况下为生命而战。
The pastor had been counselling Diane Stouty and was struck by her lack of emotion in relation to it all. He had come to believe something was seriously amiss in the stouty home. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. This episode is brought to you by IQ Bar. IQ Bar gives you the fuel and focus you need without the sugar crash. It's a filling, nutrient-rich option that keeps you energised all day. Casefile team member Andrew recently tried IQ Bar and loved the convenience and taste, especially the lemon blueberry flavour. He also appreciated the simple, healthy ingredients that provided ample protein
这位牧师一直在辅导黛安·斯托蒂，并对她对此表现出的缺乏情感感到震惊。他开始相信斯托蒂家中出了严重的问题。Casefile 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。本集由 IQ Bar 赞助。IQ Bar 为您提供所需的能量和专注力，而不会出现糖分崩溃。这是一种令人饱腹、营养丰富的选择，让您整天精力充沛。Casefile 团队成员安德鲁（Andrew）最近尝试了 IQ Bar，并喜欢它的便利性和口感，尤其是柠檬蓝莓口味。他还欣赏简单、健康的成分，这些成分提供了充足的蛋白质
and fibre. To get you in the holiday spirit, IQ Bar has released some limited-time flavours, IQ Bar Gingerbread and IQ Joe Peppermint Mocker. While wellness can often take a backseat during the holidays, IQ Bar brings you festive treats that are actually good for you. Their protein-packed bars, mood-boosting hydration sticks and brain-boosting coffee will keep you full and focused. Their ultimate sampler pack includes all three products and right now IQ Bar is offering our podcast listeners an exclusive deal. 20% off all IQ Bar products plus get free shipping. With over 15,000 5-star reviews and counting, IQ Bar makes the number one brain and body nutrition bar, hydration mix,
和纤维。为了让您感受到节日气氛，IQ Bar 发布了一些限时口味，IQ Bar 姜饼味和 IQ Joe 薄荷摩卡味。虽然健康在节日期间往往会被搁置一旁，但 IQ Bar 为您带来实际上对您有益的节日美食。他们富含蛋白质的能量棒、提神补水棒和健脑咖啡将让您保持饱腹和专注。他们的终极采样包包括所有三种产品，现在 IQ Bar 为我们的播客听众提供独家优惠。所有 IQ Bar 产品八折优惠，外加免运费。凭借超过 15,000 条 5 星评价且还在增加，IQ Bar 打造了美国排名第一的健脑和身体营养棒、补水混合物，
and instant coffee in the US. Snack smarter with IQ Bar. There's more fibre, less sugar, and they're entirely free from gluten, dairy, and artificial sweeteners. And right now, IQ Bar is offering our special podcast listeners 20% off all IQ Bar products plus get free shipping. To get your 20% off, just text CASEFILE to 64000. Text CASEFILE to 64000.
和速溶咖啡。用 IQ Bar 聪明地吃零食。它含有更多的纤维，更少的糖，并且完全不含麸质、乳制品和人工甜味剂。现在，IQ Bar 为我们特别的播客听众提供所有 IQ Bar 产品八折优惠，外加免运费。要获得八折优惠，只需发送短信 CASEFILE 到 64000。发送短信 CASEFILE 到 64000。
That's CASEFILE to 64000. Message and data rates may apply. See terms for details. A lot has changed over the past year. Casefile has expanded its team, launched a new Casefile Presents series and even started hosting public events with Me On Stage. If you have a growing e-commerce business, you can relate. Whether you're looking for better efficiency during the hectic holiday season, or your business has outgrown your old shipping solutions, you need ShipStation to help you scale your business. Casefile team member Paulina signed up to ShipStation for her Shopify store and was
即发送 CASEFILE 到 64000。可能会收取短信和数据费。过去一年发生了很多变化。Casefile 扩大了团队，推出了新的 Casefile Presents 系列，甚至开始与 Me On Stage 举办公共活动。如果您有不断增长的电子商务业务，您会感同身受。无论您是在繁忙的假日季节寻求更高的效率，还是您的业务已经超出了旧的运输解决方案，您都需要 ShipStation 来帮助您扩展业务。Casefile 团队成员宝琳娜（Paulina）为她的 Shopify 商店注册了 ShipStation，并对
blown away by how easy it was to automate shipping tasks. With everything managed in one simple dashboard, Paulina can track orders and print shipping labels with just a click. If you're looking to take your e-commerce business to the next level, ShipStation is the tool you need. It's the fastest, most affordable way to ship products to your customers, with discounts up to 89% off UPS, DHL Express and USPS rates. Plus, you can seamlessly integrate with the services and selling channels you already
自动化运输任务的简便程度感到震惊。通过在一个简单的仪表板中管理所有内容，宝琳娜只需点击一下即可跟踪订单并打印运输标签。如果您想将电子商务业务提升到一个新的水平，ShipStation 是您需要的工具。这是向客户运送产品最快、最实惠的方式，UPS、DHL Express 和 USPS 的费率折扣高达 89%。此外，您可以与您已经使用的服务和销售渠道无缝集成，
use, making it easier than ever to manage everything in one place. Scale your e-commerce business with the shipping software that delivers. Switch to ShipStation today. Go to shipstation.com code CASEFILE. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Police went to speak with the physicians treating Sarah Stouty. They had performed multiple tests to identify what was impacting her, but everything medical or genetic was ruled out. Although there was no trace of alcohol, illicit drugs or poisons in Sarah's system,
使在一个地方管理所有内容变得比以往任何时候都更容易。用能够交付的运输软件扩展您的电子商务业务。今天就切换到 ShipStation。访问 shipstation.com 并使用代码 CASEFILE。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供高质量的内容。警方去与治疗莎拉·斯托蒂的医生交谈。他们进行了多次检查以确定是什么影响了她，但所有医疗或遗传因素都被排除了。虽然莎拉的体内没有酒精、非法药物或毒药的痕迹，
a doctor remarked that her condition was very suspicious. A nurse had more to add. Sarah was barely clinging to life, but her mother Diane had only visited her a couple of times. Moreover, Diane's behaviour was described as inappropriate. She joked and laughed with hospital staff about her daughter's condition and said that she planned to go on a vacation to Florida soon, regardless of Sarah's status. Police came to learn that Diane had also acted strangely after her husband and son's deaths. According to friends of the Stouties, Diane treated Mark's memorial service like a party. She displayed no outward expressions of grief and seemed more concerned
一位医生评论说她的情况非常可疑。一位护士还有更多要补充的。莎拉几乎奄奄一息，但她的母亲黛安只来看过她几次。此外，黛安的行为被描述为不恰当。她与医院工作人员开玩笑，谈论她女儿的病情，并说她计划很快去佛罗里达度假，不管莎拉的情况如何。警方了解到，黛安在丈夫和儿子去世后也表现得很奇怪。据斯托蒂家的朋友说，黛安把马克的追悼会当成了派对。她没有表现出任何悲伤的表情，似乎更关心
about being the perfect host and making sure guests were catered to. When a neighbour saw the coroner's van outside the Stouty home after Shaun's death, she rushed over to check on the family. Diane answered the door and the neighbour asked if everything was alright. Diane responded casually, Oh yeah, my son died. Online Diane barely mentioned her husband and son beyond brief obligatory death notices. Within days, she was back to posting positive Bible quotes and silly memes. As detectives began re-examining the deaths of Mark and Sean Stouty,
作为一名完美的主人，确保客人们得到照顾。当一位邻居在肖恩去世后看到斯托蒂家门外的验尸官货车时，她赶过去查看这家人。黛安开了门，邻居问一切是否还好。黛安随意地回答：“哦，是的，我儿子死了。”在网上，黛安除了简短的强制性死亡通知外，几乎没有提到她的丈夫和儿子。几天之内，她又开始发布积极的圣经引语和愚蠢的表情包。当侦探们开始重新审查马克和肖恩·斯托蒂的死亡时，
Diane agreed to be interviewed, unaware that any investigations were taking place. She was first asked about Sarah. Diane explained how a week earlier Sarah had complained of a mild headache and stomach upset which resulted in her vomiting a few times. To Diane, Sarah's illness didn't seem that bad as she had seen worse cases of the flu. Sarah spent most of her time in bed only emerging to vomit into the toilet. She had no appetite but was able to take fluids. Diane said Sarah's usual schedule consisted of her staying up all night with friends and sleeping during the day so she hadn't noticed anything was seriously off until Sunday.
黛安同意接受采访，不知道任何调查正在进行中。她首先被问及莎拉的情况。黛安解释说，一周前莎拉抱怨有轻微的头痛和胃部不适，导致她呕吐了几次。对黛安来说，莎拉的病看起来并不严重，因为她见过更严重的流感病例。莎拉大部分时间都躺在床上，只有在去厕所呕吐时才会出来。她没有食欲，但能喝流质。黛安说莎拉平时的作息是整晚和朋友待在一起，白天睡觉，所以直到周日她才注意到有什么严重的问题。
That morning Sarah was bedridden and unable to attend church. The rest of the family went without her. When they returned home at around 12.30pm, Sarah was still in bed, seemingly resting. Hours passed before Diane went to check on her again. By then, Sarah was unresponsive. Diane carried Sarah out to the car and rushed her to the hospital. Despite being a trained nurse, Diane was mystified as to what had caused Sarah's illness. All she could say was that it had done a number on her. When asked if Sarah might have harmed herself, Diane said that was a possibility. Sarah had bipolar disorder like her father and had threatened self-harm in the past.
那天早上，莎拉卧床不起，无法去教堂。其余家人在没有她的情况下去了教堂。当他们在下午 12:30 左右回家时，莎拉还在床上，似乎在休息。几个小时过去了，黛安才再次去查看她。那时，莎拉已经没有反应了。黛安把莎拉抱到车里，冲向医院。尽管是一名受过培训的护士，黛安还是对导致莎拉生病的原因感到困惑。她唯一能说的是，这让她受了很大的罪。当被问及莎拉是否可能伤害自己时，黛安说这是一种可能性。莎拉像她父亲一样患有双相情感障碍，过去曾威胁要自残。
But Diane asserted that her daughter's behaviour had been fine lately. She'd also checked Sarah's medication and it appeared normal, ruling out the possibility that she had overdosed on it. Diane suggested that Sarah might have, quote, gotten into the cleaners, meaning that she could have intentionally consumed poisonous household cleaning products. Diane was asked to be more specific. She responded with a laugh, what do I have? I can't see her taking soap, yuck. soap, yuck. Diane was then asked what she thought happened to Sarah. She fell silent for a moment before replying with an exasperated sigh, I really don't know, I've been trying to rack my brain to figure out what happened.
但黛安断言她女儿最近的行为一直很好。她还检查了莎拉的药物，看起来很正常，排除了她过量服用的可能性。黛安暗示莎拉可能“接触了清洁剂”，意思是她可能故意食用了有毒的家用清洁产品。黛安被要求更具体一点。她笑着回答：“我有什么？我看不出她会喝肥皂，真恶心。”然后黛安被问及她认为莎拉发生了什么事。她沉默了一会儿，然后叹了口气，无奈地回答：“我真的不知道，我一直在绞尽脑汁想弄清楚发生了什么。”
I really can't think of anything. I don't know. It just doesn't make sense." Diane was told that further tests would be carried out to establish what exactly happened to Sarah. When asked if she thought anything suspicious might be found, Diane responded, might be found, Diane responded, I have no clue. I don't even know what to look for. I mean, if they're looking for some kind of chemical that she may have taken, I can't think of what it would be. And if the tests did come back confirming the presence of a chemical, how would Diane explain explain that. She shrugged her shoulders and answered, I don't know. Mark and Sean Stouty were both cremated, but Sean was autopsied beforehand. As part of that process, the medical
“我真的想不出任何事情。我不知道。这根本说不通。”黛安被告知将进行进一步的检查，以确定莎拉到底发生了什么。当被问及她是否认为可能会发现任何可疑之处时，黛安回答：“我一点头绪都没有。我甚至不知道该找什么。我的意思是，如果他们是在寻找她可能服用的某种化学物质，我想不出那会是什么。”如果检查结果确实证实了化学物质的存在，黛安会如何解释呢？她耸了耸肩回答：“我不知道。”马克和肖恩·斯托蒂都被火化了，但肖恩在火化前进行了尸检。作为该过程的一部分，法医
examiner had taken samples of Sean's tissue, blood, and hair. The samples were stored for a certain amount of time post-mortem, allowing for additional testing to take place if necessary. Although Mark wasn't autopsied, samples of the dried blood around his mouth had been collected and similarly stored. The interviewing detective asked Diane, The interviewing detective asked Diane, Is there any reason that from samples taken that there might be some sort of correlation, some kind of link, something that might be similar between them? Diane gently shook her head and replied, I don't know. The detective pressed on.
提取了肖恩的组织、血液和头发样本。样本在死后被储存了一段时间，以便在必要时进行额外的检查。虽然马克没有进行尸检，但嘴边干涸的血迹样本已被收集并以同样的方式储存。采访的侦探问黛安：“是否有任何理由表明从样本中提取的物质之间可能存在某种相关性、某种联系，或者有什么相似之处？”黛安轻轻摇了摇头回答：“我不知道。”侦探继续追问。
And if there was, what would your explanation be? Diane repeated, I don't know. The detective then abruptly asked, What was Mark's life insurance policy like? Diane divulged that Mark's $20,000 life insurance payout had helped pay for a nicer home. Diane intended to use Sean's $15,000 payout for bills. Sarah's policy would net Diane a further $15,000. Her other two daughters' amounts were the same. Diane was asked what she would spend Sarah's life insurance payout on. I have no clue, she replied. By now Diane's mood had shifted. She'd become solemn and contemplative, allowing for long moments of silence before answering questions. When asked if there was anyone that would want to harm her family, Diane claimed that Mark had a lot of weird acquaintances who were into drugs. As for her kids, she said,
“如果有的话，你的解释会是什么？”黛安重复道：“我不知道。”侦探随后突然问道：“马克的人寿保险单是什么样的？”黛安透露，马克 2 万美元的人寿保险赔付帮助支付了一套更好的房子。黛安打算用肖恩 1.5 万美元的赔付来支付账单。莎拉的保单将为黛安带来另外 1.5 万美元。她另外两个女儿的金额也是一样的。黛安被问及她会把莎拉的人寿保险赔付花在什么地方。她回答说：“我一点头绪都没有。”此时黛安的情绪已经发生了变化。她变得庄重而沉思，在回答问题前留下了长时间的沉默。当被问及是否有人会想伤害她的家人时，黛安声称马克有很多吸毒的怪异熟人。至于她的孩子们，她说：
I can't imagine anybody trying to harm them. Diane was encouraged to open up about her marriage with Mark. She eventually admitted that it wasn't good, saying that Mark had a binge drinking problem, a cannabis habit, and had been unfaithful to her. Diane could never bring herself to kick him out as she feared he would take his own life. When Mark died, it was actually a relief. I just don't tell people that, Diane admitted, before adding, despite all his faults, I still loved him. I still loved him." Suspecting Diane was holding back information, the interviewing detective appealed to her religious beliefs. Referring to her as a God-fearing woman, he asserted that the right thing to do was to
“我无法想象有人会试图伤害他们。”黛安被鼓励敞开心扉谈论她与马克的婚姻。她最终承认婚姻并不好，说马克有酗酒问题、大麻习惯，并且对她不忠。黛安一直无法狠心把他赶走，因为她担心他会自杀。当马克去世时，这实际上是一种解脱。“我只是不告诉别人，”黛安承认，然后补充说，“尽管他有种种缺点，但我仍然爱他。”怀疑黛安隐瞒了信息，采访的侦探诉诸她的宗教信仰。他称她为敬畏上帝的女人，并断言正确的事情是
speak honestly and ask for forgiveness. He told her, I think you're a very good lady with the right intentions. Everybody reaches a tipping point or a breaking point. Maybe certain decisions are made that normally wouldn't be made. Often times the best way to ask for forgiveness is to talk about it and give an explanation. Diane expressed fear of going to jail. She was told to put that thought aside and to just focus on showing remorse and seeking forgiveness. Finally, after two hours of questioning, Diane flatly admitted, To put it really short and sweet, I knew they were drinking antifreeze. Antifreeze is an additive that lowers the freezing point of a water-based liquid. It is used in vehicles to stop the water in the engine cooling system from freezing during winter months. Commonly known
诚实地说话并寻求宽恕。他告诉她：“我认为你是一位心地善良、初衷良好的女士。每个人都会达到一个临界点或崩溃点。也许会做出一些平时不会做出的决定。通常，请求宽恕的最好方法是谈论它并给出解释。”黛安表达了对坐牢的恐惧。她被告知要把那个想法放在一边，只专注于表现出悔意并寻求宽恕。最后，在两个小时的审讯后，黛安直截了当地承认：“简单明了地说，我知道他们在喝防冻液。”防冻液是一种降低水基液体冰点的添加剂。它用于车辆中，以防止发动机冷却系统中的水在冬季结冰。通常被称为
as engine coolant, antifreeze can be purchased at motoring supply shops and gas stations and is a common item found in residential garages. It is extremely hazardous when ingested. It only takes a small amount of antifreeze to poison the human body, with symptoms appearing gradually over several hours. The impacted person can feel or appear inebriated and suffer from headaches, fatigue, lack of coordination, grogginess, slurred speech, nausea, and vomiting. As the body breaks down the antifreeze, the chemical can interfere with kidney, lung, brain and nervous system function, with organ damage occurring 24 to 72 hours after ingestion. It results in rapid breathing, a racing heartbeat and convulsions, concluding with loss of consciousness
发动机冷却液，防冻液可以在汽车用品店和加油站购买，是住宅车库中常见的物品。摄入后极其危险。只需少量防冻液就会使人体中毒，症状在几个小时内逐渐出现。受影响的人会感到或看起来醉酒，并出现头痛、疲劳、缺乏协调、昏昏沉沉、言语不清、恶心和呕吐。当身体分解防冻液时，该化学物质会干扰肾脏、肺、大脑和神经系统的功能，器官损伤在摄入后 24 到 72 小时内发生。它会导致呼吸急促、心跳加速和抽搐，最终导致失去知觉
and death. Diane Stouty was asked how she knew her family members were drinking antifreeze. She replied, Because I saw them drinking it. I didn't know what else to do. I really didn't. Diane admitted that she had reached a breaking point. She claimed she didn't want to hurt her family, she was just mad. She was tired of working hard to provide for them while they took advantage of her and showed little appreciation. In Diane's words, Mark was a deadbeat who stayed home drinking, smoking and enjoying his music. Diane had grown to hate
和死亡。黛安·斯托蒂被问及她是如何知道她的家人在喝防冻液的。她回答说：“因为我看到他们在喝。我不知道还能做什么。我真的不知道。”黛安承认她已经到了崩溃的边缘。她声称她不想伤害她的家人，她只是很生气。她厌倦了努力工作来供养他们，而他们却利用她，表现出很少的感激之情。用黛安的话说，马克是一个在家喝酒、抽烟和享受音乐的游手好闲的人。黛安开始憎恨
her husband and said he lashed out violently at her and their kids. She couldn't stand being with him any longer, so she killed him. She did the same to Sean because she was fed up with caring for him. She described Shawn as more than a bother, more than a pest, who was always interfering in everything she did. Shawn's autism prevented him from holding down a job. Diane felt he was being wilfully disobedient in his inability to contribute to the household. She felt the same towards Sarah. They often argued about how Sarah didn't try hard enough to get a job. Diane killed Sarah because she didn't want to wind up paying off her student loan debt. She felt very differently about her two youngest children, Rachel and Tia. They treated her well and caused no grief, so Diane hadn't poisoned them. She put it bluntly, I'm not a perpetual killer. I'm just stupid. I regret doing it. I really do. I've screwed up everybody. I've screwed up my whole family."
她的丈夫，并说他暴力地对待她和他们的孩子。她再也无法忍受和他在一起，所以她杀了他。她对肖恩做了同样的事，因为她厌倦了照顾他。她形容肖恩不仅仅是一个麻烦，不仅仅是一个害虫，总是干涉她所做的一切。肖恩的自闭症使他无法保住工作。黛安觉得他在无法为家庭做出贡献方面是故意不服从。她对莎拉也有同样的感觉。他们经常争论莎拉没有足够努力地找工作。黛安杀死了莎拉，因为她不想最终偿还她的学生贷款债务。她对两个最小的孩子瑞秋和蒂亚的感觉非常不同。她们对她很好，没有造成任何痛苦，所以黛安没有毒害她们。她直言不讳地说：“我不是一个惯犯。我只是愚蠢。我后悔这么做了。我真的后悔。我搞砸了所有人。我搞砸了我的整个家庭。”
Diane had researched online and learned about the harmful qualities of antifreeze. It was easy to acquire and because of its sweet taste and lack of odour, easy to disguise. No one would suspect Mark, Sean or Sarah had been poisoned with antifreeze unless medical personnel knew to look for it, as its symptoms were similar to many normal ailments. Furthermore, the chemical's raw components were easily missed in an autopsy because they weren't part of normal toxicology screenings and required advanced testing to detect. Diane ordered bottles of antifreeze online and poured a couple of teaspoons into Gatorade for Mark and Coca-Cola for her children. She served the lethal concoction to her unsuspecting victims
黛安在网上进行了研究，了解了防冻液的有害特性。它很容易获得，而且由于其甜味和无味，很容易伪装。没有人会怀疑马克、肖恩或莎拉是被防冻液毒死的，除非医务人员知道要检查它，因为它的症状与许多普通疾病相似。此外，该化学物质的原始成分在尸检中很容易被遗漏，因为它们不是常规毒理学筛查的一部分，需要先进的检测才能发现。黛安在网上订购了瓶装防冻液，并往马克的佳得乐（Gatorade）和孩子们的可口可乐中倒了几茶匙。她把致命的混合物端给了她毫无戒心的受害者。
over a period of several weeks. The poison took effect within days but often just resulted in mild flu-like symptoms. When Diane's target didn't die quick enough, she increased the dosage of antifreeze until it had its desired effect. Following Diane's shocking confession, detectives arrested her and began seeking more information about the Stoutie family dynamic. Sarah was still in hospital and 11-year-old Tia was traumatised by her family's ongoing suffering. Yet there was still one other sibling who could provide some insight. 22-year-old Rachel Stouty agreed to speak with police. She was unaware that her mother had admitted to poisoning her father, brother and older sister. In contrast to Diane's account, Rachel said that Mark was a nice dad who fostered his children's independence. She admitted that
在几周的时间里。毒药在几天内就起了作用，但通常只会导致轻微的流感样症状。当黛安的目标没有足够快地死去时，她增加了防冻液的剂量，直到达到预期的效果。在黛安令人震惊的供述之后，侦探们逮捕了她，并开始寻求更多关于斯托蒂家庭动态的信息。莎拉还在医院，11岁的蒂亚因家庭持续遭受的苦难而受到创伤。然而，还有另一个兄弟姐妹可以提供一些见解。22岁的瑞秋·斯托蒂同意与警方交谈。她不知道她的母亲已经承认毒害了她的父亲、兄弟和姐姐。与黛安的说法相反，瑞秋说马克是一位好父亲，他培养了孩子们的独立性。她承认
her parents argued a little bit over money, but no more than any other married couple. Sometimes Diane took issue with Mark's friends as they drank and smoked. Rachel recalled her parents breaking a table during one disagreement, but overall they were close and had a pretty good relationship. She saw no abuse and the only bad things she had to say about her father had come from her mother. As for Shaun, Rachel said he was extremely low maintenance. All he needed was a puzzle or comic book and he was, quote, a happy camper. Sean was independent and content being alone, hardly the imposing pest Diane had made him out to be. Rachel didn't consider him to be a burden at all. He had a good relationship with his siblings, especially Sarah. Rachel said that when Sean
她的父母在金钱问题上吵过一点架，但并不比任何其他已婚夫妇多。有时黛安会对马克的那些喝酒抽烟的朋友有意见。瑞秋回忆说，她的父母在一次争吵中弄坏了一张桌子，但总的来说，他们很亲近，关系也相当不错。她没有看到任何虐待行为，她对父亲唯一不好的评价都是从她母亲那里听来的。至于肖恩，瑞秋说他非常省心。他所需要的只是一本拼图或漫画书，他就是，引用她的话，“一个快乐的露营者”。肖恩很独立，满足于独处，绝不是黛安所描述的那种令人讨厌的麻烦。瑞秋根本不认为他是一个负担。他和他的兄弟姐妹，尤其是莎拉，关系很好。瑞秋说，当肖恩
was sick, everyone took turns looking after him, though their mother primarily cared for him during the day while she worked from home. Diane gave him Coca-Cola as it was one of the few things he could stomach. When asked about her mother's reaction to Sean's passing, Rachel said Diane wished they could have done more for him. She felt like a failure as a mum, because it was one thing to lose your husband, but far worse to lose a child. Rachel remembered when Sarah fell ill too. The toilet was right across from her bedroom, and at night she could hear Sarah going in to vomit. Rachel tried to convince Sarah to eat, but she had no appetite. She could manage to drink though, so Rachel and Diane would
生病时，每个人都轮流照顾他，尽管他们的母亲在白天工作时主要照顾他。黛安给他喝可口可乐，因为这是他少数能吃得下的东西之一。当被问及她母亲对肖恩去世的反应时，瑞秋说黛安希望他们能为他做更多的事。她觉得自己作为一个母亲很失败，因为失去丈夫是一回事，但失去孩子要糟糕得多。瑞秋记得莎拉也生病的时候。厕所就在她卧室对面，晚上她能听到莎拉进去呕吐。瑞秋试图说服莎拉吃东西，但她没有胃口。不过她还能喝水，所以瑞秋和黛安会
bring her fluids. Things eventually deteriorated to the point where Sarah couldn't get up off the floor. When she lost consciousness, Rachel helped carry her out to the car and take her to the hospital. According to Rachel, Diane expressed guilt over Sarah's predicament too, lamenting that she should have taken her to the hospital sooner. Rachel also recalled the time Sarah had threatened to self-harm. It was during middle school and Rachel was certain it was only a cry for help. Since then, Sarah hadn't expressed any suicidal thoughts. She had been a high achiever at college and was otherwise doing well. Rachel admitted that Sarah wasn't trying very hard to find work, though her options were limited.
给她送流食。情况最终恶化到莎拉无法从地板上站起来。当她失去知觉时，瑞秋帮忙把她抬到车上并送往医院。据瑞秋说，黛安也对莎拉的困境表示内疚，感叹她应该早点带她去医院。瑞秋还记得莎拉曾经威胁要自残的时候。那是在中学时期，瑞秋确信那只是在寻求帮助。从那以后，莎拉再也没有表达过任何自杀念头。她在大学里成绩优异，其他方面也做得很好。瑞秋承认莎拉并没有很努力地找工作，尽管她的选择有限。
She had degrees in French and History and her interests lay in teaching or translating French, but there weren't many opportunities in Missouri as most students learnt Spanish. It was normal for Sarah to spend the day on her computer watching videos online instead of helping out around the house. Rachel was more frustrated with Sarah than her mother seemed to be. Although Diane was disappointed by Sarah's lack of effort, she was patient with her. Rachel had never seen them arguing. Diane would bring up Sarah's unemployment during normal conversations, but it was never in a heated way, more so a gentle nudging. more so a gentle nudging. Rachel admitted that she'd found the situation with her father, brother and sister weird. She worried that their terminal condition was hereditary and she would
她拥有法语和历史学位，她的兴趣在于教书或翻译法语，但在密苏里州机会不多，因为大多数学生学习西班牙语。莎拉整天在电脑上看在线视频而不是帮忙做家务是很正常的。瑞秋对莎拉的沮丧程度似乎比她母亲要高。虽然黛安对莎拉的不努力感到失望，但她对她很有耐心。瑞秋从未见过她们争吵。黛安会在正常的谈话中提起莎拉失业的事，但从来不是以激烈的方式，更多的是一种温和的提醒。瑞秋承认，她觉得父亲、兄弟和姐妹的情况很奇怪。她担心他们的绝症是遗传的，她会
catch it next. Diane had reassured her, saying that Mark had a heart problem, Sean's death was due to his seizures, and Sarah's illness was out of the blue. Diane led Rachel to believe that she would be fine. After Rachel had revealed all of this, a detective told her kindly, kindly. What has happened is your mum has admitted to killing your dad and your brother and trying to kill your sister with poison. I know it's hard to process and a hard thing to even think about, but she basically spelled it out to us how she did this and the reasons for doing it." Rachel sat in shock as the truth set in. She then began to sob as the detective asked, did you have any suspicions that Mum was doing anything?
接下来也染上。黛安安慰她，说马克有心脏问题，肖恩的死是因为他的癫痫发作，而莎拉的病是突如其来的。黛安让瑞秋相信她会没事的。在瑞秋透露了所有这些之后，一名侦探和蔼地告诉她：“发生的事情是，你妈妈已经承认毒杀了你的父亲和兄弟，并试图毒杀你的姐妹。我知道这很难接受，甚至很难去想，但她基本上向我们详细说明了她是如何做到这一点的，以及这样做的原因。”瑞秋在真相大白时感到震惊。当侦探问“你有没有怀疑过妈妈在做什么？”时，她开始啜泣。
Rachel tearfully explained that she knew her mother was frustrated, but she had no idea that she wanted to harm their family. she had no idea that she wanted to harm their family. Meanwhile, a search of the stouty home uncovered evidence pertaining to Diane's crimes, including a bottle of Prestone brand antifreeze engine coolant in the garage. Next to it was a six pack of Coca-Cola. Examination of a laptop revealed that between searches for Christian sheet music and funny cat videos were many others relating to fatal essential oils, poisons used in suicides, herbs that cause stroke, and where to purchase rat poison. The same laptop was used days after Mark Stouty's death to determine lethal doses of over-the-counter
瑞秋含泪解释说，她知道母亲很沮丧，但她根本不知道母亲想伤害他们的家人。与此同时，对斯托蒂家的搜查发现了与黛安罪行有关的证据，包括车库里的一瓶Prestone牌防冻发动机冷却液。旁边是一打六罐装的可口可乐。对一台笔记本电脑的检查显示，在搜索基督教乐谱和搞笑猫咪视频之间，还有许多其他与致命精油、自杀毒药、导致中风的草药以及在哪里购买老鼠药有关的搜索记录。同一台笔记本电脑在马克·斯托蒂死后几天被用来确定体重48公斤的成年人服用非处方药的致死剂量。
pain relief medication for adults weighing 48kg. This was Sean Stouty's weight. Officers searched a bedroom and noticed a purple notebook sitting on top of a shelf. The word JOURNAL was printed across the the front cover and the pages inside were full of handwritten musings about the day-to-day happenings of the Stouty family. An entry dated Monday June 11, 2011 stood out. It read, Sometimes I wish I could avoid the future and keep looking to the past. It's sad when I realise how my father will pass on in the next two months and how Sean, my brother, will move on shortly after. And yet, it's really helpful. I'm being warned so I have more time to prepare and cope. Also, I get to have Dad's car when he's gone. It'll be tough getting used to the changes, but everything will work out.
这就是肖恩·斯托蒂的体重。警官搜查了一间卧室，注意到架子上放着一本紫色笔记本。封面印着“日记”二字，里面的页面写满了关于斯托蒂家日常琐事的手写感想。2011年6月11日星期一的一条记录很显眼。它写道：“有时我希望我能逃避未来，继续回顾过去。当我意识到我的父亲将在接下来的两个月内去世，而我的兄弟肖恩不久后也会离开时，这很令人难过。然而，这真的很有帮助。我得到了警告，所以我有了更多的时间来准备和应对。此外，当爸爸走后，我可以得到他的车。习惯这些变化会很艰难，但一切都会好起来的。”
Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. This is a public service announcement for renters. If you haven't heard of BILT, you're about to thank me. Paying rent through BILT, you're about to thank me. Paying rent through BILT lets you earn points that can go toward flights, hotel stays, fitness classes, and even your next rent payment. Let me break it down for you. There's no cost to join BILT, and as a member you'll earn valuable points on rent and on your everyday spending.
案件档案节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。这是一则针对租房者的公益广告。如果您还没听说过BILT，您很快就会感谢我。通过BILT支付房租，您可以赚取积分，这些积分可用于航班、酒店住宿、健身课程，甚至是您的下一笔房租支付。让我为您详细说明。加入BILT无需任何费用，作为会员，您将在支付房租和日常消费中赚取宝贵的积分。
BILT points can be transferred to your favorite hotels and airlines and even the ones you haven't heard of. There are over 500 airlines and 700,000 hotels and properties around the world you can redeem your built points toward. Points can also be redeemed towards a future rent payment and unique experiences that only BUILT members can access. So if you're not earning points on rent, my question is, why not? Start earning points on rent you're already paying by going to joinbuilt.com slash casefile.
BILT积分可以转让给您最喜欢的酒店和航空公司，甚至是您没听说过的那些。全球有超过500家航空公司和70万家酒店及物业可以使用您的BILT积分进行兑换。积分还可以兑换未来的房租支付以及只有BILT会员才能享受的独特体验。所以，如果您还没有通过房租赚取积分，我的问题是，为什么不呢？前往joinbuilt.com/casefile，开始为您已经支付的房租赚取积分。
That's J-O-I-N-B-I-L-com.com slash case file. Make sure to use our URL so they know we sent you. Joinbuilt.com slash case file to start earning points on your rent payments today. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. On her Facebook page, Diane Stouty once posted the quote, never miss an opportunity to tell your child I love you. Despite this, only one Stouty child received the bulk of her affection. Diane's third oldest, Rachel, was her perfect golden child. Unlike Sean, Sarah and Taya,
那是J-O-I-N-B-I-L-T.com/casefile。请务必使用我们的网址，这样他们就知道是我们推荐您来的。访问Joinbuilt.com/casefile，立即开始为您支付的房租赚取积分。感谢您收听本节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。在她的Facebook页面上，黛安·斯托蒂曾发布过这样一句话：“永远不要错过告诉你的孩子我爱你的机会。”尽管如此，只有一个斯托蒂家的孩子得到了她大部分的爱。黛安的第三个孩子，瑞秋，是她完美的“金童”。与肖恩、莎拉和蒂亚不同，
22-year-old Rachel was uncomplicated. She didn't face the same struggles as her siblings and was a successful overachiever. She excelled in school, spoke four languages and played multiple musical instruments. She loved maths, chemistry, art and poetry. Diane plastered her Facebook page with praise directed at Rachel, while her other children barely rated a mention. It was clear Rachel was Diane's favourite and the pair shared a remarkably close, best friend type bond. They understood one another and confided in each other. Rachel also confided in her personal diary, a journal with a purple cover that she kept on a shelf in her bedroom.
22岁的瑞秋性格单纯。她没有像她的兄弟姐妹那样面临同样的挣扎，是一个成功的优等生。她在学校表现优异，会说四种语言，并演奏多种乐器。她热爱数学、化学、艺术和诗歌。黛安在她的Facebook页面上贴满了对瑞秋的赞美，而她的其他孩子几乎没有被提及。很明显，瑞秋是黛安的最爱，两人有着非常亲密、闺蜜般的关系。她们互相理解，互诉衷肠。瑞秋还在她的个人日记中倾诉，那是一本有着紫色封面的日记本，她把它放在卧室的架子上。
Mark and Sean were killed nearly a year after the entry Rachel made predicting their deaths, well over the two-month deadline she had anticipated. Yet the fact she even knew about them beforehand was surprising. And a search of Rachel's purse uncovered a poem she had written after Sarah was hospitalised. It read, Once upon a time there were six and now there are only three. Only the quiet ones are left. My mum, my little sister, and me. In Diane's police interview, she had insisted that no one else knew what she'd done. During Rachel's interview, she was asked directly if she had any involvement in her mother's scheme. you, she was asked directly if she had any involvement in her mother's scheme. Rachel had shook her head no and cried. Following the discovery of Rachel's diary, police conducted
马克和肖恩在瑞秋预测他们死亡的记录近一年后去世，远超过了她预期的两个月期限。然而，她事先就知道这一点的事实令人惊讶。对瑞秋钱包的搜查发现了一首她在莎拉住院后写的诗。诗中写道：“从前有六个人，现在只剩下三个。只剩下安静的人。我的妈妈，我的小妹妹，还有我。”在黛安的警方审讯中，她坚称没有其他人知道她所做的事。在瑞秋的审讯中，她被直接问及是否参与了她母亲的计划。瑞秋摇了摇头，哭了。在发现瑞秋的日记后，警方进行了
another interview with her. They kept word of the find to themselves and instead just asked how she felt about what her mother had done. Rachel said she was confused and shocked, explaining, "...no one expects to have somebody that they know do that. I mean, who judges who can live?" Detectives then asked, "...did your mother ever say anything to you about any of your family members being in bad health and that they were going to die in the near future? Rachel said that her mother had spoken about Mark smoking and drinking. She said if he kept it up then he wasn't going to make it to the age of 80. Rachel claimed that Diane had never mentioned anything about Sean or Sarah's future. that Diane had never mentioned anything about Sean or Sarah's future. Rachel was shown a banal entry from the Purple Journal found in the Stouty home. She confirmed the diary was hers and that
另一次审讯。他们对发现日记的事守口如瓶，只是问她对自己母亲所做的事情有何感想。瑞秋说她感到困惑和震惊，解释道：“……没有人会想到自己认识的人会做出这种事。我是说，谁来评判谁能活下去？”侦探们随后问：“你母亲有没有对你说过关于你家人的健康状况不好，他们会在不久的将来死去的话？”瑞秋说，她母亲确实谈到过马克抽烟喝酒。她说如果他继续这样，他就活不到80岁。瑞秋声称黛安从未提到过关于肖恩或莎拉未来的任何事情。瑞秋被展示了在斯托蒂家中发现的紫色日记中的一条平淡记录。她确认日记是她的，并且
she had written the entries within. She was then shown the entry where she predicted Mark and Sean's deaths. Rachel thought for a moment before explaining that she had a dream around that time that Mark and Sean would die. She claimed she told her mother about the dream. What did you tell your mother? the police asked. Rachel started to sob tearlessly as she replied. That it would be quick and easy, that they'd be in heaven soon and we could move on. Rachel continued to open up, stating matter-of-factly, I didn't know when my mother bought the antifreeze, but I knew she'd been doctoring drinks with that. Although the interviewing detective was stunned by Rachel's admission,
她写下了其中的记录。随后她被展示了那条预测马克和肖恩死亡的记录。瑞秋思考了一会儿，解释说她在那个时候做了一个梦，梦见马克和肖恩会死。她声称她把这个梦告诉了母亲。“你告诉了你母亲什么？”警方问。瑞秋开始无声地啜泣，回答道：“说这会很快很容易，他们很快就会在天堂，我们可以继续生活。”瑞秋继续敞开心扉，实事求是地陈述道：“我不知道我母亲是什么时候买的防冻液，但我知道她一直在用那个给饮料下毒。”尽管审讯的侦探对瑞秋的供述感到震惊，
he remained cool and kept asking questions. Rachel admitted that her mother had confided in her about her intention to kill the others. She offered more insight as to how the plan came to fruition. After Diane settled on antifreeze as her murder weapon, she purchased it online. This was because antifreeze sold in stores has an added bittering agent to prevent accidental ingestion. Diane kept a small amount of antifreeze hidden in a container under the kitchen sink. She would tip out two inches or so of whatever drink she'd poured for Mark, Sean or Sarah and then refill it with the poison. By this point in Rachel's interview she'd admitted to knowing that her mother was intending to kill family members, but maintained that she'd acted alone. Yet,
但他保持冷静并继续提问。瑞秋承认，她母亲曾向她吐露过杀害其他人的意图。她提供了更多关于该计划如何实现的见解。在黛安决定使用防冻液作为谋杀武器后，她从网上购买了它。这是因为商店里出售的防冻液添加了苦味剂，以防止误食。黛安把少量的防冻液藏在厨房水槽下的一个容器里。她会倒掉给马克、肖恩或莎拉倒的饮料中的两英寸左右，然后用毒药补满。到瑞秋审讯的这一阶段，她已经承认知道她母亲打算杀害家人，但坚称她是独自行动的。然而，
when explaining how Diane researched by reading a book about poisonous plants, Rachel initially said we would, before quickly correcting her answer to she would. Detectives suspected they weren't getting the full story. They told Rachel that they'd seized the laptop she and Diane shared and asked what they'd find on it. Rachel admitted that she had once searched… how to kill someone. The interviewing detective then asked a risky question, not expecting to receive the answer he was looking for. Your mother would pour some of the drink out and then she would put the antifreeze in the drink and then give it to your father. How
当解释黛安是如何通过阅读一本关于有毒植物的书进行研究时，瑞秋最初说“我们”，然后迅速纠正为“她”。侦探们怀疑他们没有得到全部真相。他们告诉瑞秋，他们已经查封了她和黛安共用的笔记本电脑，并询问他们会在上面发现什么。瑞秋承认她曾经搜索过……如何杀人。审讯的侦探随后问了一个冒险的问题，没指望得到他想要的答案。“你母亲会倒掉一些饮料，然后把防冻液放进饮料里，再给你父亲。你做了多少次？”
often did you do that? After thinking for a moment, Rachel replied coolly, Once. The detective was stunned. When he pressed Rachel to be honest, she clarified her answer. Three, four times. This gradual drip feed of information formed the basis of Rachel's confession. She would initially give a broad, uncertain or deceptive answer before being grilled with follow-up questions. Eventually, she gave detailed, consistent answers that aligned with the facts of the case. She was first interrogated about her father's death. It was a trade-off, Rachel said casually. Mum would do it, then I would. Rachel mixed the drinks for her father twice a day, once in the morning and once in the evening, for several weeks. She didn't have a clear schedule with her mother, who typically administered her
在思考了一会儿后，瑞秋冷静地回答：“一次。”侦探惊呆了。当他催促瑞秋诚实回答时，她澄清了答案。“三、四次。”这种逐渐滴入的信息构成了瑞秋供述的基础。她最初会给出宽泛、不确定或欺骗性的回答，然后被后续问题盘问。最终，她给出了与案件事实相符的详细、一致的回答。她首先被审问关于她父亲的死亡。瑞秋随意地说，这是一种交换。妈妈做一次，然后我做一次。瑞秋连续几周每天两次为她父亲混合饮料，一次在早上，一次在晚上。她和她母亲没有明确的时间表，她母亲通常在下午进行
poisonings in the afternoon, so they often overlapped and served many poisoned drinks to Mark a day. As Rachel's story unraveled, it was clear she'd participated in the poisonings more than just the three or four times she had initially admitted to. Mark didn't fall sick at first. Diane reassured Rachel, telling her, it will take time. It was several weeks before Mark finally became ill. The women continued to poison him with higher doses. By the end, Mark's drinks consisted of half soda or Gatorade and half antifreeze. Diane and Rachel went through upwards of five bottles of antifreeze in their efforts to
投毒，所以她们经常重叠，每天给马克提供许多杯毒饮料。随着瑞秋的故事展开，很明显她参与投毒的次数远不止她最初承认的三四次。马克起初并没有生病。黛安安慰瑞秋，告诉她：“这需要时间。”几周后，马克终于病倒了。女人们继续用更高剂量毒害他。到最后，马克的饮料由一半苏打水或佳得乐和一半防冻液组成。黛安和瑞秋在她们试图杀害他的过程中用掉了五瓶以上的防冻液。
kill him. Despite having previously praised her father, Rachel now claimed that Mark was killed because he was turbulent and abusive. This was at odds with her own diary where Rachel had written that her father would, quote, rather cut off his own arm than hurt us. Nevertheless, she went on to write that her father was still more of a hindrance alive. Rachel said she mixed a drink a day for Shaun and one every so often for Sarah, but mostly used bottles of Coca-Cola or Gatorade that Diane had pre-mixed in advance.
尽管之前曾称赞过她的父亲，但瑞秋现在声称马克被杀是因为他性格暴躁且有虐待行为。这与她自己的日记相矛盾，瑞秋在日记中写道，她的父亲“宁愿砍掉自己的手臂也不愿伤害我们”。然而，她接着写道，父亲活着仍然是一个障碍。瑞秋说她每天为肖恩混合一杯饮料，偶尔为莎拉混合一杯，但大多使用黛安预先混合好的可口可乐或佳得乐瓶子。
Wen asked, why did you guys want to kill them? Rachel replied indifferently, Shaun, I accepted that Mum wanted him gone, but I really didn't think he was necessary. After further pressing, Rachel admitted that she found Shaun annoying. As for Sarah, Rachel said, I really actually wasn't aware that Mum was getting Sarah. I knew about Shaun, I knew about Dad, but I didn't know she was going to go ahead with Sarah." As usual, Rachel's lies didn't hold up under further scrutiny. She soon admitted that she had known about the plan to kill Sarah a month beforehand. As to why they wanted Sarah dead, Rachel explained, other than the fact that she basically lived in the back bedroom and didn't have any gumption to get a job, I'm not certain. Mum probably has her own issues with her. The detective asked,
当被问及“你们为什么要杀他们？”时，瑞秋冷漠地回答：“肖恩，我接受妈妈想让他走，但我真的觉得没必要。”在进一步追问下，瑞秋承认她觉得肖恩很烦人。至于莎拉，瑞秋说：“我真的不知道妈妈要对莎拉下手。我知道肖恩的事，我知道爸爸的事，但我不知道她还要对莎拉下手。”像往常一样，瑞秋的谎言在进一步审查下站不住脚。她很快承认，她在一个月前就知道杀害莎拉的计划。至于为什么她们想让莎拉死，瑞秋解释说：“除了她基本上住在后卧室里，没有动力去找工作之外，我不确定。妈妈可能对她有自己的看法。”侦探问，
The detective asked, what about you? Rachel took a deep breath before replying, she's annoying yes, but I don't know. Rachel eventually admitted that she found Sarah very nosy and they fought all the time. She added bluntly, back in middle school Sarah would touch me. I mean, she grew out of it later when she got on the medicine, but she still argues. She still has really inappropriate jokes. She really had no purpose." Rachel clarified that the touching she was referring to was both physical and sexual, but Sarah acted like she couldn't remember it. Despite the seriousness of these allegations and the fact that Rachel was implying deep prolonged trauma had motivated her to kill Sarah, she never referred to it again.
侦探问：“那你呢？”瑞秋深吸了一口气，回答道：“她很烦人，是的，但我不知道。”瑞秋最终承认她觉得莎拉非常爱管闲事，她们总是吵架。她直言不讳地补充道：“在中学时，莎拉会碰我。我是说，她后来吃药后改掉了，但她还是会争吵。她还是会开非常不恰当的玩笑。她真的没什么用。”瑞秋澄清说，她所指的触碰既是身体上的也是性方面的，但莎拉表现得好像不记得了。尽管这些指控很严重，而且瑞秋暗示长期深层的创伤促使她杀害莎拉，但她再也没有提起过这件事。
Investigators thought it was convenient that Rachel said Sarah had no recollection of it either. As Rachel was a proven liar, they believed she'd made up the shocking accusation to make Sarah's murder appear understandable. It still didn't provide any justification as to why she'd participated in killing Mark and Sean beforehand. Rachel made yet another revelation. She claimed Sarah was in on the murder plot too. Police were incredulous. If Sarah was aware of and involved in the plan to poison Mark and Shaun, then she would know not to accept any drinks herself, especially once she started developing symptoms. Rachel said that when Sarah fell ill she asked them, am I going to die or will I die soon? Rachel and Diane would reply, I don't know. Sarah didn't ask or accuse them of poisoning her despite allegedly knowing that they had done it twice before.
调查人员认为，瑞秋说莎拉也不记得这件事很方便。由于瑞秋是一个被证明的骗子，他们认为她编造了这一令人震惊的指控，使莎拉的谋杀看起来可以理解。这仍然没有为她之前参与杀害马克和肖恩提供任何正当理由。瑞秋又做了一个披露。她声称莎拉也参与了谋杀阴谋。警方表示怀疑。如果莎拉知道并参与了毒害马克和肖恩的计划，那么她就会知道不要接受任何饮料，特别是在她开始出现症状之后。瑞秋说，当莎拉生病时，她问她们：“我会死吗，或者我会很快死去吗？”瑞秋和黛安会回答：“我不知道。”莎拉并没有询问或指责她们毒害她，尽管据称她之前两次知道她们这样做过。
Nor did she reach out to anyone else or seek help on her own volition. In Rachel's own words, Sarah was very afraid of death and often talked about not wanting to die. Detectives felt that these actions didn't align with the narrative that Sarah knew what her mother and sister were up to. Then there was the question as to why Diane and Rachel had taken Sarah to the hospital for treatment. Rachel revealed this wasn't done due to any sense of care, compassion or a desire to save Sarah's life. It was Rachel's idea because she, quote, didn't want another one to die in the house, cause houses are nasty after somebody's died in it. After Shaun died, Rachel moved into his room
她也没有联系其他人或主动寻求帮助。用瑞秋自己的话来说，莎拉非常害怕死亡，经常谈论不想死。侦探们认为这些行为与莎拉知道她母亲和姐妹在做什么的说法不符。然后还有一个问题，为什么黛安和瑞秋带莎拉去医院治疗。瑞秋透露，这不是出于任何关心、同情或拯救莎拉生命的愿望。这是瑞秋的主意，因为她“不想让另一个人死在家里，因为有人死在家里后，房子会很恶心”。肖恩死后，瑞秋搬进了他的房间，
and was plagued by nightmares. She said it was awful that she kept sensing a ghostly presence in the space and she didn't want to experience that again when Sarah passed. Rachel's fear seemed genuine. She was uncharacteristically nervous and shaky when discussing the haunting in Sean's room. She had also written about it in her diary immediately following Sean's death. Quote, Yet I feel your gaze lingering over me. I close my eyes and try not to think of the ghosts of copper and bleach. On my tongue, I try not to think of shuddery breaths or how easily a soul evaporates, leaving nothing behind but a hollow husk curled up on the floor, eyes vacant and dull, arms extended. But what were you reaching for?
并被噩梦困扰。她说，她一直感觉到空间里有鬼魂存在，这太可怕了，她不想在莎拉去世时再次经历那种感觉。瑞秋的恐惧似乎是真实的。在讨论肖恩房间里的闹鬼事件时，她表现出不同寻常的紧张和颤抖。她在肖恩死后立即在日记中写道：“然而，我感觉到你的目光在我身上徘徊。我闭上眼睛，尽量不去想铜和漂白剂的鬼魂。在我的舌头上，我尽量不去想颤抖的呼吸，或者灵魂是多么容易蒸发，什么也没留下，只剩下一个蜷缩在地板上的空壳，眼睛空洞而暗淡，手臂伸展。但你在伸手去拿什么？”
What were you reaching for?" As for the youngest stouty child, Tia, Rachel admitted that she and Diane had planned to kill her after Sarah. The motive was similar to Sean. Tia's learning disabilities were a burden and they didn't want to look after her. Rachel remarked, after her. Rachel remarked, I know there's no way in hell I'd be able to take care of Tia. I can't take care of me, so how could I ever take care of her? Following Rachel's harrowing confession, police re-interviewed Diane. Upon learning that her daughter had confessed, Diane made full admissions that she and Rachel had planned, researched, and committed the crimes together. Neither woman expressed a genuine remorse or regret. Nor did Diane show any hint of sadness for sacrificing Rachel's promising future in
“你在伸手去拿什么？”至于斯托蒂家最小的孩子蒂亚，瑞秋承认她和黛安计划在莎拉之后杀掉她。动机与肖恩相似。蒂亚的学习障碍是一个负担，她们不想照顾她。瑞秋评论道：“我知道我绝对不可能照顾蒂亚。我连自己都照顾不好，怎么可能照顾她？”在瑞秋令人心碎的供述之后，警方重新审讯了黛安。在得知女儿已经供述后，黛安完全承认她和瑞秋一起计划、研究并实施了这些罪行。两人都没有表现出真正的悔恨或遗憾。黛安也没有表现出任何为牺牲瑞秋的前途而感到悲伤的迹象，
favour of grooming her to be her partner in crime. By the time Diane and Rachel's deadly plot was exposed, Sarah Stouty's condition had changed dramatically. Although hospital staff had given her a 0% chance of survival when she was first admitted. In a miraculous turn of events, she was slowly recovering. Both Diane and Rachel were surprised to learn of Sarah's survival, though not relieved. Rachel had even nodded her head and said yes when asked if she still wanted Sarah to die. But Sarah's ordeal wasn't over. The strokes and seizures she'd endured left her with severe neurological damage. She had to relearn to walk and talk. When Sarah was well enough, she agreed to a police interview. She hadn't yet been informed that her mother and sister had confessed to poisoning her.
反而培养她成为自己的犯罪同伙。当黛安和瑞秋的致命阴谋被曝光时，莎拉·斯托蒂的情况发生了巨大变化。尽管医院工作人员在莎拉刚入院时给了她0%的生存机会。在奇迹般的转折中，她正在缓慢康复。黛安和瑞秋在得知莎拉幸存时都很惊讶，但并不感到宽慰。当被问及是否仍然希望莎拉死时，瑞秋甚至点了点头说“是”。但莎拉的磨难还没有结束。她所经历的中风和癫痫发作给她留下了严重的神经损伤。她不得不重新学习走路和说话。当莎拉身体状况好转时，她同意接受警方采访。她还不知道她的母亲和姐妹已经承认毒害了她。
Investigators wanted to get to the bottom of Rachel's claim that Sarah had known about their crimes. Sarah was told that police had been investigating why she had fallen sick. been investigating why she had fallen sick. What do you think we found out, detectives asked. Sarah replied, I don't know. When asked if she thought anyone would try to hurt her, Sarah said, no, all I know is that I got sick. Sarah was then informed that her mother and sister had admitted to making her unwell. Sarah went on to recount an experience she'd had after Mark and Sean died. One day, she found her mother's personal diary. Sarah opened it and found an entry Diane had written about Mark and Sean's deaths. To Sarah's shock,
调查人员想弄清瑞秋关于莎拉知道她们罪行的说法。莎拉被告知警方一直在调查她为什么会生病。侦探问：“你认为我们发现了什么？”莎拉回答：“我不知道。”当被问及是否认为有人会试图伤害她时，莎拉说：“不，我只知道我生病了。”随后，莎拉被告知她的母亲和姐妹已经承认是她们让她生病的。莎拉接着讲述了她在马克和肖恩死后的一次经历。有一天，她发现了她母亲的个人日记。莎拉打开它，发现了一条黛安写的关于马克和肖恩死亡的记录。令莎拉震惊的是，
the entry also referred to her own death. Unnerved, Sarah confronted her mother, but her concerns were dismissed and she was warned not to go looking in the diary again. Sarah said this hadn't alerted her to the fact that her mother or sister were responsible for making Mark, Sean, or herself sick. Sarah flat out denied being involved in any part of the scheme, and nothing that was uncovered suggested she'd known what was going on. Detectives believed Sarah, but in any case, her brain had been seriously damaged by the antifreeze. It was obvious from their conversations that her mind was foggy and she didn't fully
这条记录也提到了她自己的死亡。不安的莎拉质问了她的母亲，但她的担忧被驳回了，并被警告不要再去看日记。莎拉说这并没有让她意识到她的母亲或姐妹应对马克、肖恩或她自己生病负责。莎拉断然否认参与了该计划的任何部分，也没有任何发现表明她知道发生了什么。侦探们相信莎拉，但无论如何，她的大脑已经被防冻液严重损坏。从他们的谈话中可以明显看出，她的思维很模糊，并没有完全
comprehend what was being asked. Given Sarah's condition and the lack of evidence pertaining to her guilt, detectives ended these inquiries with the belief that she was an innocent victim. Diane Stouty was ultimately charged with two counts of first degree murder for Mark and Sean, as well as one count of first degree assault and one of armed criminal action for the crimes against Sarah. Rachel Stouty was charged with the same offences. In May 2015, three years after the poisonings began, Rachel pleaded guilty as part of a deal. In exchange for testifying against her mother at trial, Rachel would be eligible for parole one day. at trial, Rachel would be eligible for parole one day. At her sentencing, Rachel read an apology she had penned to her sister Sarah. In it, she claimed she was haunted by the reality of loss and grieved
理解被问到的问题。鉴于莎拉的情况以及缺乏她有罪的证据，侦探们结束了这些调查，认为她是一个无辜的受害者。黛安·斯托蒂最终被控两项一级谋杀罪（针对马克和肖恩），以及一项一级袭击罪和一项针对莎拉的武装犯罪行为罪。瑞秋·斯托蒂被控同样的罪名。2015年5月，在投毒开始三年后，瑞秋作为协议的一部分认罪。作为在审判中出庭指证她母亲的交换条件，瑞秋将来有资格获得假释。在量刑听证会上，瑞秋宣读了一封她写给姐姐莎拉的道歉信。在信中，她声称自己被失去的现实所困扰，并为
knowing that her guilt wasn't a passing phase. Quote, your suffering could have been prevented and I hate myself for not being there for you. Things will never be the same, but I can try to change to become a better person. I want you to know that you are an inspiration to me. Thank you for showing me what I can be. Rachel Stouty, who was now 25 years old, was sentenced to life in prison with the possibility of parole in 42 years. In January 2016, Diane Stouty also accepted a plea deal. She agreed to plead guilty to all but the armed criminal action charge in order to avoid potentially receiving the death penalty if the case went to trial.
知道她的罪恶感不是暂时的而感到悲伤。引用：“你的痛苦本可以避免，我恨自己没有在你身边。一切都不会再一样了，但我可以尝试改变，成为一个更好的人。我想让你知道，你是我的灵感来源。谢谢你向我展示了我可以成为什么样的人。”现年25岁的瑞秋·斯托蒂被判处终身监禁，42年后有假释可能。2016年1月，黛安·斯托蒂也接受了认罪协议。她同意对除武装犯罪行为罪以外的所有指控认罪，以避免如果案件进入审判可能面临的死刑。
She was subsequently sentenced to life in prison without parole. Since her incarceration, Diane has changed her story yet again. In a 2022 interview with ABC's 2020, Diane claimed that she was completely innocent. She said that her husband was associated with dangerous people who'd put out a hit on him. Someone from within that circle was responsible for poisoning him. She even went on to claim that she had been poisoned at one point, though she offered no explanation as to how Sean and Sarah came to be victims as well. A case detective clarified, There is nothing whatsoever to show that anybody was involved in this case other than those mentioned already.
她随后被判处终身监禁，不得假释。自入狱以来，黛安又一次改变了她的说法。在2022年接受ABC《20/20》采访时，黛安声称她是完全无辜的。她说她的丈夫与危险人物有联系，那些人对他下了追杀令。那个圈子里的人应对毒害他负责。她甚至声称自己也曾一度被下毒，尽管她没有解释肖恩和莎拉是如何也成为受害者的。一名案件侦探澄清说：“没有任何证据表明除了已经提到的那些人之外，还有其他人参与此案。”
other than those mentioned already. If Rachel Stouty hadn't incriminated herself in her diary, there was a very real possibility that her involvement in the poisonings would have never been uncovered. A clinical and forensic psychologist told A&E that the diary entries were evidence of how much control Diane exerted over Rachel. It had reached the point where Rachel was fully convinced of her mother's scheme, believing it was, quote, just the way it has to be. Therefore, she journaled about it as if it were any other mundane experience she was dealing with in her life. As a result of Sarah Stouty's permanent neurological damage, she now lives in an assisted care facility and has a state-appointed guardian. Sarah was unable to care for her youngest sibling Tia, who was consequently placed in foster care. In a statement read aloud in court, Sarah said, I prefer to be a survivor than a victim. She intends to fulfil her dream of travelling to France
如果瑞秋·斯托蒂没有在日记中自证其罪，她参与投毒的事实很有可能永远不会被发现。一位临床和法医心理学家告诉A&E，日记记录证明了黛安对瑞秋的控制力有多强。事情已经发展到瑞秋完全相信她母亲的计划，认为这“只是必须发生的方式”。因此，她像记录生活中任何其他平凡经历一样记录了这件事。由于莎拉·斯托蒂的永久性神经损伤，她现在住在辅助护理机构，并有一名国家指定的监护人。莎拉无法照顾她最小的妹妹蒂亚，蒂亚因此被寄养。在法庭上宣读的一份声明中，莎拉说：“我宁愿做一个幸存者，也不愿做一个受害者。”她打算实现去法国旅行的梦想，
and becoming a translator. In the meantime, Sarah campaigns to raise awareness of antifreeze poisoning. Following Sarah's ordeal, she struggled the most with how much she missed her father and brother. She lives her life believing their spirits protect her. Quote, Mark and Sean are like angels watching over me, and every once in a while I have dreams that they visit me.
并成为一名翻译。与此同时，莎拉开展活动以提高人们对防冻液中毒的认识。在莎拉的磨难之后，她最痛苦的是她有多么想念她的父亲和兄弟。她生活在相信他们的灵魂在保护她的信念中。引用：“马克和肖恩就像守护着我的天使，偶尔我会梦见他们来看我。”
Although Sarah was angry when she found out her mother and sister had poisoned her, she has since moved past this feeling. I forgive them for what they did, because forgiveness is the right thing to do. I can hear explosions, I didn't know what was happening. I'm Vicki Petratus. And I'm Emily Webb. We are true crime authors and podcasters with a long history of interviewing people who've experienced unthinkable events. The next guy had this Molotov cocktail in his hand and I just saw him lighting it. Are you listening? Pay attention.
虽然莎拉在发现母亲和姐妹毒害她时很生气，但她此后已经走出了这种感觉。“我原谅她们所做的一切，因为宽恕是正确的事情。”“我能听到爆炸声，我不知道发生了什么。我是维基·佩特拉图斯。”“我是艾米丽·韦伯。我们是真实犯罪作家和播客主持人，有着采访经历过不可思议事件的人的长期历史。”“下一个人手里拿着这个莫洛托夫鸡尾酒，我看到他点燃了它。你在听吗？注意听。”
We're at Link Cafe. A gentleman has taken us hostage. He's got a gun and he's got a bomb. He turned towards me and he had this demonic look on his face and just came at me. These stories will have you on the edge of your seats. My shield man wasn't there anymore. It was me by myself. I had no protection. We are going to die now. Who could get out of that situation? I could hear explosions. I didn't know now. Who could get out of that situation?
“我们在Link咖啡馆。一位绅士劫持了我们。他有一把枪，还有一个炸弹。”“他转向我，脸上带着那种恶魔般的表情，直接向我冲来。”“这些故事会让你坐在座位的边缘。”“我的盾牌手不在那里了。是我自己。我没有任何保护。”“我们现在要死了。”“谁能从那种情况下逃脱？”“我能听到爆炸声，我不知道发生了什么。”
I could hear explosions, I didn't know what was happening. It's just a matter of self-preservation, get myself out of there. We get to ask questions that most would never ask. And because of that, we get told things most would never hear about. And I couldn't get my gun out, I'm sort of fighting with him, he's stabbing me.
“我能听到爆炸声，我不知道发生了什么。这只是自我保护的问题，让自己离开那里。”“我们有机会问大多数人永远不会问的问题。正因为如此，我们被告知大多数人永远不会听到的事情。”“我无法拿出我的枪，我正和他在搏斗，他在刺我。”
Maybe he just hit his head on the ground when he went down, maybe he's okay. I saw that she wasn't in a very good way. Yeah, this will be difficult for me to talk about. What draws us to these stories is the strength of the people coming out the other side of what they've been through. But it was eight years before I processed what happened in the siege. There is a way. It's not going to be easy. You might have pitfalls, but you've got to keep going. I'm not going to let it beat me or defy me. So even though these are stories of the unthinkable, they are also stories of hope.
“也许他倒下时只是头撞到了地上，也许他没事。”“我看到她的情况不太好。”“是的，谈论这件事对我来说会很困难。”“吸引我们关注这些故事的是那些经历过这一切后走出来的人的力量。”“但那是八年后，我才消化了围攻中发生的事情。”“有一种方法。这不会容易。你可能会遇到陷阱，但你必须继续前进。”“我不会让它打败我或定义我。”“所以，尽管这些是不可思议的故事，但它们也是希望的故事。”
You've got to be the best for you first before you can be the best for someone else. The Unthinkable is available now. Be sure to download and follow The Unthinkable wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“你必须先成为最好的自己，然后才能成为别人的最好。”《不可思议》现已上线。请务必在您获取播客的任何地方下载并关注《不可思议》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。